When we put all these pieces together, what we get is actually a function. We
can tell, since it passes the vertical line test. This kind of function is
called a Piecewise function because, well, it's defined in different pieces.
Since different functions are defined in different parts of the domain, there
have to be at least two different equations defined in different parts of the
domain for a function to be considered a Piecewise function. What I'd like to
know, is what part of the domain each of these functions occupies? I'm going to
switch over to Piecewise function notation right now so that you can get an
idea of what that looks like. So this is what typical Piecewise function
notation looks like. You can see that instead of separate equations for each
part of the line over here, we've effectively merged them into one using this
brace, this curly thing right here. This shows that all of these different
function pieces are part of a single function f of x. Now the other important
feature of Piecewise function notation, is this section over here to the right.
This is where we show the domain that each part of the function occupies.
Often, you'll see a comma used between the equations for the different parts of
the functions and their domain. But sometimes you'll see the word for written
in here instead like this. To save space, I'm going to use commas right now.
But either way is acceptable. Now, looking at the graph, and thinking back to
what you learned about Grant's tax brackets before. Please fill in the
different numbers that belong in these boxes to show what the domain of each
piece of the function is. Now I've been nice, and I've already filled in the
inequality signs for you, so all we need here are the numbers.